The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Let's
try the countdown again.
You can just give
it to them for now.
We'll figure it out later.
I like to ask people
to explain, now
that they know what
the right answer is,
if someone will explain why
that is the right answer.
And I know it's a big
class, and people sometimes
get nervous about talking.
So I bribe people.
So today, the person who
answers why that is correct
will get an MIT
chemistry T-shirt.
OK.
AUDIENCE: All right, let's see.
If you're using 5
moles of N2, you
need 15 moles of hydrogen gas.
Since there's not
enough hydrogen gas--
there's only 10 moles-- that
means the hydrogen gas should
be the limiting reactant since
you would need roughly 3.33
moles of N2 for it.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Great.
And here is an MIT
chemistry T-shirt.
[APPLAUSE]
CATHERINE DRENNAN: OK, so you'll
notice that the prizes are
good in the beginning, get
worse throughout the semester,
and get good again at the end.
So keep that in mind.
OK, so let's try to get started.
It's been a little
bit of a crazy start.
If people are still
having clicker problems,
we have a couple more clicker
questions that you can try out.
And we'll get your clickers
working by the end of class
today.
So the topics--
today, we're going
to be talking about the
discovery of the electron
and of the nucleus.
And I said that there's
going to be limited amounts--
or every time I have a
lecture that has some history,
I'm going to counter that
with some modern chemistry.
So next week,
we're going to have
two examples of modern uses.
But today, we're going
to do a little history.
And I like history,
especially when
it can lead to a cool demo.
So you might have noticed
something demo-like came in
while we were
doing the clickers.
So that's always good.
And I also like
talking about history
when I feel like it's a
great example of a challenge
that chemists face, and
really, most scientists
face, that they used to face
and still currently face,
which is that chemists
study small particles.
They study things
that are really tiny.
How do you study something
that's really small?
How do you demonstrate
that something
that is invisible to
the eye actually exists?
So this is a common challenge.
And so today, I'm
going to tell you
about how the electron
and the nucleus
were discovered at
a very low-tech time
in our scientific
history, how they
were able to figure this out.
And let me just set the stage
of what people were thinking
around this time, and how
these discoveries really
changed everything.
So in the late 1890s, chemists
were patting each other
on the back.
And physicists too were
thinking, boy, we have it
all figured out.
We have a real, complete
understanding of our universe.
We have atomic theory of matter.
We have Newtonian mechanics.
This is really great.
And in fact, someone
said these words,
which are really
dangerous words,
that our future
discoveries must be looked
for in the sixth decimal place.
So honestly, when I
started studying chemistry,
I thought everything
about chemistry
was probably already known.
And it was just
fine tuning things.
I was absolutely
wrong at that time.
And this statement
was absolutely wrong,
and it really came right
before the major discovery
of the electron, where they
realized they hadn't really
understood anything about
the atomic theory of matter.
So more experiments are
always dangerous because they
can change everything.
And that's why I
really like science.
All right, so the experiment
I'm going to tell you today,
JJ Thompson's discovery
of the electron.
Or one of the experiments
I'll tell you about today,
and this is really a
pretty simple experiment.
So JJ Thompson was interested in
this thing called cathode rays.
He had hydrogen gas, and then
he took an evacuated glass
cylinder.
And he put hydrogen gas in it.
And then he applied
a current to that,
and he could see
these rays coming off.
And he thought that
was pretty cool.
And so he was wondering
about these rays.
Are they made up of
negatively charged particles,
possibly charged
particles, maybe neutral?
What are these things?
So he decided to
do this experiment.
And he wondered whether
if he took two plates
and had charges associated
with them, whether he
would see the cathode
rays deflected or not.
Well, first, he didn't
apply any current,
so it was just neutral, just to
see if putting these plates in
would affect
anything in any way.
And so when he did
that, when there
was zero voltage difference
between these two plates,
he could see the cathode ray
hit this phosphor screen.
And there was no deflection.
All right, then he
said, OK, now, I'm
going to charge things up, and
see if I can see a deflection.
So he did that, and
he saw the following.
There was a deflection.
And so now, the different
voltage between the plates
was greater than 0.
And now, he saw
the cathode ray was
being deflected a different
distance of delta x over here.
And it was being deflected
toward the positive plate.
So that said to him that
the cathode ray contained
negatively charged particles.
You'll notice that the word
"negatively" is the only word
on the screen in blue.
And if you look at
your notes, you'll
see that there's a blank spot.
Just pointing out there
might be a correlation there.
OK, so he knew some things
also from classical work
that was done in the time.
And I didn't reset my boards.
So he knew something
about what it meant
if there was just deflection.
So we had our deflection of the
negatively charged particles.
And he knew that
that was going to be
proportional to the
charge of the negatively
charged particle.
And it was going to be
directly proportional to that,
and inversely proportional
to the mass of the negatively
charged particle.
So it was a pretty big
deflection, so he wasn't sure.
Maybe there was a
very big charge,
or maybe there was a very
small mass, or maybe both.
So then he wanted to see
what happened if he really
got things going,
and he applied even
more of voltage difference.
So he did that.
And when he did
that, he saw this.
He saw another deflection, but
this time, it was much smaller.
And it was toward the
negatively charged plate.
So he realized that, in addition
to the negatively charged
particle, there was also a
positively charged particle.
So for that particle,
then, the deflection
of the positively
charged particle
should also be proportional to
the charge on the positively
charged particle, and inversely
proportional to the mass
of the positively
charged particle.
But there was a big
difference in this deflection.
Toward the positive plate,
there was a big deflection.
And toward the negative
plate, it was pretty small.
So he knew that this deflection
was much bigger than that one.
And then he thought
about-- is that going
to be due to charge or mass?
But he said, the charges
should be the same
because it's neutral normally.
So those charges must equal
each other, the absolute values
at least, must equal each other.
So then we can think
about the comparison
of these deflections.
So if we can take the absolute
value of the deflection
of the negatively
charged particle
over the absolute value of the
deflection of the positively
charged particle,
on the top here,
we're going to have the
charge of the negatively
charged particle over the
mass of the negatively
charged particle.
And the absolute
value of that term
over the charge
of the positively
charged particle, over the
mass of the positively charged
particle.
But now, if you say
that the charges are
equal to each other, at least
the absolute values of them,
we can get rid of that term.
And just see that the mass
then, of the positively charged
particle over the negatively
charged particle, remains.
So if this is going to be
big, and we know it is,
it's a big difference.
The negatively charged
particle deflected
a lot more than the
positively charged particle.
That means that the difference
in masses also has to be big,
and that that negatively charged
particle must be a lot smaller
in mass than the positively
charged particle.
So if we go up a
little bit here-- oops.
So the mass of the
negatively charged particle
must be a lot smaller than the
mass of the positively charged
particle.
And actually, it's about
2,000 times smaller.
So he was able to
figure all this out
by just doing this
pretty simple experiment.
So he had now a small,
negatively charged particle,
and also a positively
charged particle.
And later, the negatively
charged particle got a name.
The negatively charged particle
got the name of the electron.
And its mass was determined
in an another interesting
experiment I won't
tell you about.
And it was determined to be
really small, about 9 times 10
to the minus 31 kilograms.
So through this
experiment, he was
able to figure out, that
in these cathode rays,
you had something that
was tiny, this electron.
And that means this idea that
atoms were the smallest thing
out there was incorrect.
That's what everyone believed.
They were patting
themselves on the back.
They had figured it all out.
But there was something
smaller than the atom.
There was this electron,
this negatively
charged particle
that was really tiny.
So it is pretty cool.
It's a pretty
low-tech experiment
that figured out something that
really changed the way that we
thought about science.
So what about the nucleus?
So we had the
electron, and we also
had this idea there was
something positively
charged going on there.
And of course, in that
experiment, that was H plus.
But what about the nucleus?
So Rutherford is credited with
the discovery of the nucleus.
So this was a little later.
And he had been studying
radioactive material.
And his good friend,
Marie Curie, from France
would often send him interesting
samples for him to study.
I'm not sure quite how they
got from France to England.
Some of these were really
cancer causing things.
I don't know how many people
touched them without safety
precautions on the way.
But anyway, it's interesting to
note that Rutherford actually
did not die of cancer,
despite this research.
He was literally the
victim of his own success.
So after his great
discovery of the nucleus,
which I'll tell you about,
he was made into a knight.
And at one point,
he became sick.
And he needed a doctor.
Well, if you're a
knight in England,
you can't just have any
old doctor treat you.
You need to have a doctor
that is also a knight.
And so while he was
waiting for a doctor
of the appropriate ranking to
come and treat him, he died.
So he literally died
of his own success.
He was a victim of
his own success.
But it wasn't just his success
as I'll tell you about.
He had some help.
He had a really good
graduate student,
a really good undergraduate
student helping him out.
So he was studying
these alpha particles
that were being emitted from
this radioactive material.
And we know now that this
is Helium plus 2 ions.
But that was not
known at the time.
They just knew
something was coming out
of this radioactive
material, and they
wanted to find out what
it was, and characterize
the properties of this.
So he had a post-doc
named Hans Geiger.
And this is the Geiger
of the Geiger counter.
And he also had an undergraduate
student, E. Marsden.
And so together, they did
the following experiment.
And I wasn't obviously there,
but I'm imagining that by "they
did the following
experiment," it
meant the undergraduate
and the graduate student,
or maybe even just
the undergraduate.
OK, so here is the experiment.
They had the
radioactive material.
Alpha particles were
coming off, and they
had built a detector that would
count how many alpha particles
were coming off.
And so they did the
experiment, and they counted.
And they found there
were a lot of particles,
132,000 alpha particles
per minute, in fact.
So then they said,
OK, let's see what
happens if we put
a piece of foil
in the path of the
alpha particles.
And we're going to have
really, really thin gold foil.
So this is like smaller
than a human hair.
This is really,
really thin foil.
And they shot alpha
particles at it.
And they counted.
And they got
approximately-- I don't
know how many significant
figures-- but 132,000 alpha
particles.
Seemed to be, in terms of the
significant figures, the same.
So it was just going through.
These alpha particles
were just going
through this thin, gold foil.
So they had this vision
then of the gold atoms
being all empty space, and
the alpha particles were just
going through, no problem.
But then they did
one more experiment.
And by then, I think this
was the undergraduate.
So they built this detector.
And they had built the
detector so it could move.
So sometimes when you design
something to do something,
you actually want
to use it for that.
So if we have the alpha
particles coming this way
and on the detector over here.
And it had been sitting,
and I've been collecting it.
The undergraduate
was told, well,
put the detector over
there, and see what happens.
So the undergraduate moved
the detector over here.
And he said, you're going to
see if the alpha particles hit
the gold foil and backscatter.
So we'll have the
detector over here.
So the undergraduate did this.
They didn't think it was
going to do anything.
They needed something for
the undergraduate to do.
So they had him do that.
And then they counted.
And sure enough, click, click.
It wasn't a lot,
but there seemed
to be some backscatter,
about 20 counts,
20 alpha particles per minute.
That was not expected.
They were expecting 0.
So they were detecting
backscattering.
The alpha particles
were bouncing off
that thin, gold foil, and coming
back at the moved detector.
So they could calculate this
probability of backscattering,
the account rate of
the backscattering
over the normal count
of the particles.
And so they had 20
backscattering events,
or 20 counts over the 132,000,
2 times 10 to the minus 4,
or 0.02%.
This is small, very small.
But it was not 0.
And I don't know how many
times they did this experiment,
but I can imagine
there were lots
of times they did the experiment
that no one would really
believe this result.
And Rutherford himself said,
"it was about as credible
as if you had fired
a 15-inch shell
at a piece of tissue paper,
and it came back and hit you."
So that's how he felt about it.
He was like, I don't
understand how this is working.
This is so thin.
It's like tissue paper, but
yet these alpha particles
are bouncing off something.
So what did this all mean,
once they had repeated
the experiment many times?
So their interpretation, then,
was that these gold atoms
were, in fact, mostly empty.
It seemed like all the
alpha particles were just
going through.
Most of them were just
passing through and not
hitting anything.
But there was something in
there that could be hit.
There was some concentrated
mass in this volume
that, when the alpha particle
hit that directly, it
backscattered.
And they later called
this the nucleus.
So they came up then with
this new model, the Rutherford
model, where you had
mostly empty space.
But you had
concentrated mass inside
that an alpha particle might
hit and then backscatter.
And Rutherford assumed
that the electrons would
be in that empty space, and
that this positive mass was
going to be positively charged.
Because he knew the overall
atom was going to be neutral.
So just a little nomenclature.
We can think about the charge
of the electrons in the atom
as being equal to
minus Z to the e, where
Z is our atomic number,
and e is the absolute value
of the electron's charge.
And if this term is negative,
then the charge on the nucleus
is going to be positive.
So we have positive Z to the
e, because overall, the atom
is going to be neutral.
Then Rutherford went
on to actually use
this backscattering to measure
the diameter of this positively
charged, dense part of
the atom, of the nucleus.
And he was able to
measure that diameter
as a very small number, 10
to the minus 14th meters.
So he did this with this
back scattering experiment.
So you might say, how
can you get a diameter
from this backscattering?
And so that's what we're going
to try right now ourselves.
We're going to do an experiment,
and Professor Sylvia Ceyer
originally came up with the
experiment to do in class.
And so she built the first
version of this gold foil
right here.
And originally, she
took something apart
from her own research program.
Since then, it's been
replicated so that she doesn't
have to shut down her
research lab every year when
we do this experiment in class.
So here, imagine this
as a piece of gold foil.
And it's mostly empty
space, but there
are some small, concentrated
nuclei, gold nuclei,
these Styrofoam balls.
And if we have, over
here, some alpha
particles, which we happen
to have 502 alpha particles.
If the alpha particle hits
the concentrated part,
it should back scatter.
Otherwise, it should go through.
So you are now going to
be radioactive material.
I don't know.
Is that the first time
you've been called
radioactive material?
I'm not sure.
But we're going to come around.
Everyone can have
one or two of these.
So let me just tell you.
You need to watch
your ping pong ball.
Once you get it, you
can move to the center.
Watch your ping pong ball.
If it hits the edge of this,
it's not a backscatter.
Watch if it goes through
or if it backscatters.
And you will click in whether
you had a backscatter event
or not.
And from that information,
we will calculate
the diameter of the nucleus.
Do you want to put
up the clicker?
I think everyone's good.
Do we have any more?
OK, everyone, if you want to
get up and get a better vantage
point, do so.
And let the experiment begin.
I'm moving out of the way.
OK, so go ahead, and say whether
you had 1, 2, or 0 backscatter
events.
And if your clicker
isn't working,
we'll ask you to raise
your hand and tell us,
especially if it was
a backscatter event.
Has everyone had a
chance to click in?
Has everyone clicked in?
You can't tell.
All right, we're
going to countdown.
Go ahead and click
in, and then we're
going to do the calculation.
OK, actually, we need to
calculate the actual number
of them, not the percent.
All right, so we had
some backscatter events.
So let's see if we can
use this information
to actually calculate the
diameter of the gold nuclei.
All right, so we are going
to talk about the probability
of backscattering.
So we have a probability is
equal to the number of ping
pong balls backscattered,
backscattered
over the total number.
And this will be related to
the radius of those gold nuclei
by the following.
So we have the
probability is going
to be equal to the area of
the nuclei, the total area
over the area of the whole atom.
So basically, the piece
of foil-- and then that's
going to be further equal to
the number of nuclei times
the area per nucleus, again,
over the area of all the atoms,
or the piece of foil.
OK, so we know some
of this information.
So I'm going to move this up.
You have an actual number.
36 total?
Oh, that's interesting.
OK, that's a lot
of backscattering.
OK, so we can plug in
some of these numbers now.
So we have the probability
is going to be equal.
Someone counted.
I didn't count,
but someone counted
that there were 120 nuclei.
And the area is going
to be pi r squared.
And someone measured
the entire frame,
or the size of the piece of
film, as a 139,000 centimeters
squared.
Or it was 1.39 meters squared.
OK, so we'll assume that
they counted the nuclei
to three significant figures.
So it's exactly 120.
And we'll assume that they
measured the box with three
significant figures as well.
So now we can solve
this for r, the radius,
or for the diameter.
So if we now solve
for the radius,
we'll bring the radius over.
And we'll have the square
root of the probability.
And if we take these
numbers, and I did the math.
I have a calculator,
if someone wants
to check-- 6.072 centimeters.
And then the diameter is going
to just be equal to twice that.
So we have the square
root of the probability
times 12.14 centimeters.
And now, we need to
calculate the probability.
So the probability is going to
be the number of backscatter,
which was 36.
36 over 502, someone
have a calculator?
Someone check my math.
Check math for me.
Check math, anybody.
I don't have another prize.
Thank you.
Was it 26 or 36?
I can't read up there.
AUDIENCE: You said it's
12 single or double?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Double.
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Excellent,
checking math for me, here.
AUDIENCE: I can't
do math in my head.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
roughly 500 [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
OK, 26, and so
what does this come out to be?
{}
AUDIENCE: 0.050.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: 0.050, And
now we need to plug that in.
So we have d equals the square
root of 0.050 times 12.14.
And what does that
come out to be?
2.71-- and the actual was 2.5.
Not bad.
So using methods
very similar to this,
Rutherford was
able to figure out
what the diameter
of the nucleus was.
And this was a really important
achievement of the time.
OK, so in the last few minutes,
maybe I'll move this down.
In the last few
minutes, I want to talk
about the fall out of all
of these great experiments
and all of these great results.
So we now know there is
an electron and a nucleus.
So there are
subatomic particles.
What does that mean in terms
of what people thought they
understood about atomic theory?
So we had this question then.
OK, so we have a nucleus,
positively charged,
and electron,
negatively charged.
And there's a
distance between them.
And wanted to know,
why do they stay apart?
Why does the electron not
crash into the nucleus?
So from classical
description, we
have Coulomb's Force
Law, which tells us
about the force
when you have two
charged particles, Q1 and Q2,
so the charge on the particles.
And you have over
4 times pi times
this permittivity constant
times the distance, r, squared.
So if you apply a force then,
and you have charged particles,
if those particles
have the same sign,
then acceleration
should push them apart.
The force should be
positive and repulsive.
So two things with
the same charge
don't want to be
near each other.
It's going to be repulsive.
If, like in this case,
you have two things
that have opposite
signs, acceleration
should pull them together.
And here the force should
be negative and attractive.
So that's the situation
we're in here,
positively charged nucleus,
negatively charged electron.
So let's consider
then a hydrogen atom.
It equals one
electron, one proton.
Let's think about
what happens when
you have an infinite
distance between them.
So if they're
infinitely far apart,
what is going to be the force?
You can just yell
out the answer.
AUDIENCE: 0.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: 0, right.
They don't feel each other.
They don't know anything
about each other.
They're infinitely far apart.
There's no force.
But that's not going to be
the situation in the atom.
Atoms are small.
So they're going to be
somewhat near each other.
Now, we can think
about what happens
if they're right on top
of each other and are a 0.
And here, we can try out
the clickers one more time.
OK, so we'll do 10 seconds.
Oh, the colors changed.
So most people had it's
infinitely attractive.
So infinitely attractive, like
most chemists, except Avogadro.
He's very strange looking.
OK, so if these things are
going to be close to each other,
then they should be
attracted to each other
and collapse into each other.
So why then are the
electron and the nucleus
that are infinitely
attracted to each
other-- why do they stay apart?
So Coulomb's Law is not
helping us understand this.
But it's really just talking
about the force with respect
to a distance.
It's not telling us
anything about what happens
when r changes with time.
So we'll find in chemistry
sometimes that things
are spontaneous
in one direction,
but they're also very slow.
So you don't have that
the thing doesn't happen,
it's just kinetically very slow.
So let's consider time now.
Maybe that will
help us understand
why this is not working.
It doesn't, but
let's look at that.
So what do we know about time?
What do we know about
acceleration and force in time?
We need a classical
equation of motion
that can explain how the
electron and the nucleus
could move under force.
So we have our good friend.
We have Newton's Second Law.
We have f equals Ma, force
equals mass times acceleration.
So let's think about
what this tells us
about the electron
and the nucleus.
So we can express force
as a function of velocity.
We can also do that
in terms of distance.
So now, let's think
about what's happening.
We know the force.
We can calculate the force
from the Coulomb's Force
Law, the force between the
nucleus and the electron.
And then we can think about
two different distances,
and with that force, how
fast the particles should
move toward each other.
So for the initial distance,
we can put take 0.5 angstroms,
or 0.5 times 10 to
the 10th meters,
so that's about the
radius of a hydrogen atom.
So we take that distance.
And then we want to think
about how fast that would then
go to 0.
And it's fast, approximately
10 to the 10th seconds.
Or the electron should
plummet into the nucleus
in about 0.1 nanoseconds.
It doesn't do that though.
So we have these
beautiful classical laws.
I'm a big fan of f equals Ma.
I like all these things.
But it's not working to
describe what's happening here.
So we discovered the electron,
discovered the nucleus,
but now we have a new problem.
We don't understand
why the electron isn't
plummeting into the nucleus.
So what's the problem here?
So is the problem Coulomb's
Force or Newton's Second Law?
And it turns out, as most
of you are probably aware,
it's that classical mechanics
doesn't work when you consider
things on this size scale.
So we need a new way to
describe what's going on here.
Classical mechanics
isn't working.
And so we need
quantum mechanics.
And so that is allowing us
to understand the behavior
that we're actually observing.
We're not observing
this plummeting,
so there must be a
better way to do this.
And when you're on this
really small scale,
you need a different way
to describe the behavior.
And so next week, we're going
to be moving in, and thinking
about quantum mechanics.
And if anyone's still
having clicker questions
or needs a clicker, we'll be
down here to help you out.
And otherwise, I will
see you on Monday.